[Music]
this is my whole world my nurse my mom
my sickness I'm 18 and I've never been
outside everyday was exactly the same
until Ollie
oh good you want house arrest I haven't
seen you outside once since we got here
no I'm sick
my body can't fight bacteria or
infections if I left the house I would
die where would you go if you could the
ocean the ocean that's three miles from
here and I've never seen it wish I could
meet you in person he sounds wonderful
but you can't see him
[Music]
I'm right here he's here who's here I
understand you're nervous yeah I'm
nervous
oh my you're really different than I
thought you were gonna be sexier right
[Music]
there mom I found this new part of
myself my met Holly if I don't go I
won't really know what it's like to be
alive
go back inside to know if I'm saying the
only way that I'll know if I'm outside
just try not to breathe it's uh small we
shouldn't push our luck but what do he
was it always like that it's never like
Maddie was long hydras good life it was
easier who I knew are supposed to be I
don't want to lose you I'm willing to
sacrifice everything just to live one
perfect day
[Music]
his head
[Music]